was a full podcast was a full part
camera Felipe Esparza
Rodrigo toys right here yeah man
weighing in at 315 pounds according to
he G he G the [ __ ] yeah added like
20 pounds down at Lisa right here on the
Wheels of Steel checking out the facts
and whatnot we have a special gift with
us today man ladies and gentlemen who
are the new book out mr. Jimmy oh yeah
what is that what we supposed to do I
just thought that's what's up
first you look old baddy what up dude
I'm good man welcome yeah you know I was
look at the monitor is really weird when
you're broadcasting live and I saw how
my hair was pulled back by the
headphones I got a huge forehead so I
got a little banged over there like now
before you go to radio and a promoter
sure you didn't care how the [ __ ] you
look but now that what they're taping
everything you're gonna have your whole
team makeup artists right you gotta be
ready every day now I'm gonna get rid of
those little Krusty's I know about
people walk up to you in the middle it's
like you can't be it can't be I really
like a hardcore you can't be a movie
star and a drug that it bro so you're
gonna run into people at bars in the
middle of morning getting another
elastic in a bottle you can't slipping I
got caught slipping at that I was aware
I was in Elysian Valley bro and I was I
know I wasn't a mission Bravo bomb it
was gonna hurt with other podcasts I was
a
riverdancing bro alley river broke a
glass of park row looking for a cocaine
looking for crack uh-huh there's a car
pulled over was so full I'm a big fan
before Last Comic Standing and then he
pulled over he was worried about me bro
and man I was trying to borrow 20 bucks
on him did you get what you wanted
though that's the give you a ride he by
mistake or
with drugs the party going on they have
a girl like the more I eat it they never
like it was sort of me up and I was like
I thought the real I thought if I see
about my life how [ __ ] up it was
reflecting reflective rule that burger
was worse than coke I was reflecting bro
it's that river dog was bad that's a bad
place I went to a movie premiere
yesterday you looked for that I'm only
premieres right well right now and then
I don't get I don't get invited to us
many things as you know publicist but
it's it's mostly for like radio and
stuff like I don't get to do cool stuff
like she doesn't get me unlike the list
and the clubs you know I feel like
that's a different type of publicist
like I've been invited to the Amy
Schumer premiere last night oh how was
that it was good man you know I wear a
yellow sweater I wasn't matching was the
background
yeah I never match I was like cool
Brooklyn
I heard that I was for that movie I feel
pretty yeah yellow huh I was exposed to
see more convenience but only recognized
I'm Jay Larson and Jeffrey Ross looking
for a guest spot craft service in that
movie bro there was a lot of people like
though who was to be who who who of
Hollywood bro I was a Roman Chinese
Theater no I was at the West Hollywood
you said Westwood oh the old Fox Theatre
actually yeah no ji-won huh they had
they went all out but the photo was
there was red carpet boy like for
celebrities or anybody was a good
publicist uh-huh and then there was a
big lie bro for the people who won free
tickets to go see super movie apart one
of my worst fears I go to like a movie
premiere and nobody knows who I am like
I'm walking through like the photography
line they're like excuse me what was
your name again
no no you can just keep going you can
just keep going with yeah it's like it's
during the HBO when you went to the HBO
Emmy party that's where we met you
uh-huh Emmy party that's you would you
did the red carpet in his publicist was
like going to each outlet so HBO yeah do
you wanna and
there were people passing but then you
know she was just like aw let's just
move on let's just move on so she takes
all the rejection you don't hear it I
just assume people don't know who I am
so I just like walk and then if like if
somebody's like hey Jimmy take a picture
and then I get really happy because you
know I set my bar so low and you just
like I'm sure you sure eat up you want
to talk to me I don't I don't know why
would they want to talk to me now I just
keep walking
it's my low self-esteem talking here I
went through all the things brewing
nobody asked me anything you know I went
through the home cameras about to fold a
bunch of photos then I turn the corner
to the actual Perez would ask questions
nobody brought the worst I was fast
yeah only one only one place baller TV
yeah girl bro this girl should ask you a
question about how you feel about this
question you're filming you with her
phone is an iPhone 5 question look at
you she was coming up next baller TV
shout-out supposed to be for taking the
time to interview ya take you 5 seconds
out of your time when you did catch
y'all a bro and photos they were like
this and that they're holding out like
like I want to fight this chick let me
put the penis down bro put them they put
the microphone the unity hey they don't
know how to put the microphone down can
I ask you a question but they don't join
hey oh yeah we don't Records we're
comedians like we know how to work a
microphone right so many people struggle
with the microphone either it's way too
low it's like way up in your head you
know dead huh yeah yeah man but and
funny when you pass by they don't want
to interview you man it's like they put
the microphone slowly away from well
really the worst is when your publicist
make them talk to you oh sorry you're
like that you want you to go down yeah
like this Hollywood Reporter I talked to
my guy Jimmy o yang and they have no
idea what the [ __ ] I am
like sometimes and then they ask you
questions like so tell us who you are
what you working on huh so
and then I have to like explain myself
like I'm a [ __ ] Wikipedia page or
some [ __ ] and then the more code I feel
pretty arrests or other reporter where I
can everybody so do you feel pretty
right and then like when I get to that
girl do you feel pretty and I said well
I'm gonna die here no wearing a tux I'm
trying actually suits
Jeffery olive wearing the same girl he
were at that rose so but that's how you
stand out the one everybody else yeah
where my little I will wear the Drake
shirt so I stood out there you go but
this is a [ __ ] [ __ ] man I'm [ __ ]
you know I'm I'm across the street
waiting for other legal should show with
that Bay Penn and and my publicist and
his fans passes by in a car Felipe was
so fool and now he turns around where
did you go he turns around swag nor that
fool I Love You Man he taught you
anything on a joke Trader Joe's joke
right whatever he saw standing there so
then he come he shows up he's wearing a
suit and I thought he was part of the
red car because anybody with a suit who
look like Larry David it [ __ ] is part
of this so this fool length now man
so my publication shows up so he's
standing right there you go April [ __ ]
it you want to go through the red carpet
he goes yeah so I got a man foo
oh and now I got hit man then his lady
shows up I got her in I gave him my
backstage passes to the movie theater
and the VIP after our party there you go
so I hooked up full of hot ticket right
now yeah so just a fan randomly
shout-out to Johnny and his lady Rachel
I thought that fools an actor to help me
go-go-go
everybody's an actor though he was Red
Alert so this fool gets popped up of
course before the movie starts oh he
drinks it right for everybody you just
made my year man
my mom died back at home
I've been living out of my car ah
girlfriend don't know
so this live discussed because this lie
right here just set up for him it's
gonna be good for those things month
damn but Lisa wasn't like acting a fool
right because like that that's my worst
fear it's like everytime you hook
somebody up for like some they start
like oh yeah I'm Felipe his homeboy man
and they start acting a fool or oh it's
the comedian you started off with but
they never became an [ __ ]
yeah you don't hang out with that fool
no more but everybody but you want you
goes you will do a show like in Arkansas
and into your gaming yeah your boy was
here
yeah so that guy with that promoter like
that's not really my boy you don't want
to be the [ __ ] yeah you're like nah
man first oh just a guy no yeah that
still only fifty dollars from back in
the day but now he's my boy will and he
wants 10 minutes I know huh yeah what's
up bro or yeah back hey when people she
win
that's the worst huh yeah cool I get
emails bro leg okay I'm gonna be an
Arkansas a member local comedian man I
got thousand friends yeah sometimes you
want to hook them up but then it's like
oh my you always regret it I end up
always regretted hooking anybody up cuz
yeah cuz they might bring all their
friends backstage they might twenty
questions
run the light you know like working call
the beer so what's the way my own again
oh are you gonna stay bozo [ __ ]
yeah exactly five minutes turns into ten
I want to know because I have my father
coming like that guy was told five
minutes like when I give someone a guest
but I'm just on earth in this room I'm
giving you a guest but not your whole
town I guess but yeah don't promote the
show and you're gonna be on the show you
know that [ __ ] yeah don't ask
bring your mama in the backstage she
gotta buy a ticket to don't have to be a
girl
don't bring your homie yes you show up
after your said bro get the [ __ ] out of
the theatre comedians at the end they
are some of the most selfish people
right like it's like they they're like
okay let me get some shine off of Felipe
shine and I'm gonna bring my whole
[ __ ] town
so everybody looked like oh I'm with the
dude I got an HBO special man so I'm
about to get my own HBO special let me
show my grandfather real quick I know
cuz they don't give a [ __ ] like whatever
your your material is like what your
vibe is they just try and do their thing
you know it's not it's hard to find a
team player that's a stand-up or you
hook me that's really cool but this fool
has an [ __ ] ass manager who pushes
who puts like Rodrigo Torre story with
give me yo yeah but it's just a [ __ ]
guest spot and when he shows up that
date he has his [ __ ] late his wife
there or somebody yeah she's holding a
box and they ask you in front of
everybody you're giving you money if I
saw some merch the future I don't care
but the guest spot person man
oh hey taping a shirt a wall suitcase he
got the coat racks and [ __ ] lighters and
[ __ ] yeah hey you're the guy taper this
whole set to every bad thing you need a
dice man
I know is it cool by taping us that - no
I'm just hooking you up I got my video
guy here you can tape you to you know I
mean like what you guys do Kim 50 bucks
you know yeah man you know my homeboy
gonna be here taking photos of me man
you think what are you 40 take photos of
you - oh yeah photographer bro yeah I
become this but too many more popular
you get how about this one hey Jimmy
think I did it before the show yes they
want to go to the show - yeah they did
actually buy tickets Oh maybe you'll
drag them with you
see I always just take a nap before the
show so I tell people I can't do
anything I can't do any tell them that
yeah I'm I gotta go you do you want to
go performance or do you want to go to
dinner you know I mean like a kid what's
your worst time hey that was a fan so
it's not even though like look it's just
good long hard it's just sometimes they
linger like I just wanna say say I have
a girl I'm trying to hit on I'm with
this girl right and then the fan just
don't know when to leave and the whole
time they just want to hang out I'm like
a dog like I'm trying to home like like
what are you trying to do is like oh man
let's go this on the bar let's go to
this let's go to that no all this is
like yeah I'm like bring you let you in
free they'll give you a bottle oh I know
the owner
yeah so he's people try to hook you up
and and I'm I used to fall for that
well cuz you're on a road you lonely and
[ __ ] you know and then I I need a local
person showing me like what's up but
then it's like oh dude like he's taking
me to some [ __ ] right now yeah it's
never cracked up to what they say and
they really just to make him look cool
I'm hanging out Felipe I'm hanging out
Jimmy you know he's trying to
redistribute that shine yeah exactly and
even when they tell you you dig out good
weed it's always bunk or you get that
one - that corn is giving wants to just
live that a man you know I was thinking
about starting a stand-up comedy but how
did you get started oh dude read my bio
right but yeah that for we had like here
with a wheelchair was another from the
wheelchair and he tells you a story is
like yeah so like I thought about
killing myself last year so that's why I
think I want to start comedy you know
people always think I'm funny anyway so
how do I do this and you can't just be
like I can't help you you don't have
anything you want to help that one line
uh you said comedy saved your life right
yeah
that's your responsibility
oh man and this fool gets cornered all
the time but they don't want to get to
you right no stop in Airport anymore
this is Jimmy immigrant to Emily I'm
like you white what are you from like
little Wayne Ian oh yeah people try to
relate to you like which I can't
appreciate I'm not hating on my friends
or my fans it's just like who's like yo
my grandfather was an immigrant so like
I'm like okay I appreciate that but why
why do you feel the need everybody's
grandfather was an immigrant at some
point it's hard to be an immigrant these
days yeah great-great grandpa that's
what's up though but I mean that's why I
wrote the book right but it's like I'm
not appreciate that one one kid sent me
this DM on Instagram Chinese kid he's
like I'm 15 years old my English not
very good I just came from China last
year and your book is the first English
book I read with nobody's help and I was
like oh man that's awesome and isn't
clear yeah like that that's also what
the [ __ ] is that like the problem with
having like Chinese fans is you release
a book or a movie or whatever the next
day it's on [ __ ] piratebay the next
leg yeah I'm like dude like a book that
[ __ ] typed it word for word and
put on a PDF I had a friend that was
hanging out with her so I'm peeping
windows friend always cuz some comic and
he went to Taiwan or China and he came
back with these horrible looking while
his boot
there were Nikes but they were not Nikes
instead of the swoosh it was a little
arrow hard-ass leather there's a good
fakes and yeah real the real good fakes
a bomb cuz I get somebody's cousin that
like works at the factory that you know
it's in the middle of that production
line that just takes them out for you oh
that's what you want you know so you
still in your top by bTW how to speak
English yeah man yeah Pete see Tommy
English and American culture like comic
view that's what I realize like stand-up
comedy first of all I realized as an art
form they didn't
really half that when I was growing them
in Hong Kong and that's when I realized
I was like oh [ __ ] like these people
aren't just like being funny
they were like teaching me about culture
and that's what stand-ups do right teach
about what I've dating culture for me
it's also learning about a lot of
stereotype like black people do that's
why people do that I didn't know that
you know like I learned all that from
from watching comic view coming up you
will deal humanely the whole thing huh
it was Jay Anthony Brown funny man his
crowd works amazing show ass down sit yo
ass down yeah the Easter Egg Roll when
you say it to be a repo man he took this
guy's car look at his mouth funeral oh
yeah and Jim and then like I was
watching all the BT programming like 106
in part you know freestyle Friday big
take in the basement was a Rap City man
that was awesome like seeing all the
rappers and like the music videos didn't
[ __ ] with Michael call your show on
there Michael he hosted comicview at
some point too right I don't remember
him having it that's a person I see
might be smile Rickey smiley hosted yeah
he got a bagging contest with AJ Johnson
and [ __ ] them up dogs sorry Gary
Owens right Gary over hosted a BT yeah
with the black lady right oh the only
share on her would know she would help
she play the old character
she was always cooking nevermind well
Ricky smiley came on that grand mal
character like that yeah dance is a
stripper that was a really famous
character yeah man was that before Madea
yeah cuz he busted up I've never seen ya
busted that [ __ ] out on that show don't
lie there's awesome but their Christmas
was the first one was full of coming
shows about Albuquerque New Mexico at
least letter restore Resort Casino a row
the real attorney was all over
Albuquerque New Mexico at least let the
rhetoric the legal Torres Johnny Unitas
Toby hey yo man hot would delicious this
Friday April 20 Lincoln California
turned around a casino in the Sacramento
area
Rodrigo Torres Johnny handsome Marcela
Quayle Cinco de Mayo Salt Lake City and
wiseguy is their brand new jordan
landing location when I'm doing that one
because it's over there more Latinos in
that neighborhood okay mate 8 through 12
Ignacio Colorado at ute Casino huge
that's right all that mess in college
yeah nacho Colorado may 19 all right
improv tickets going past California
Veronica California May 24th - no 27
Miami majoring first at the magic kiss
Magic City casino I'm headlining the
ultimate Miami comedic competition then
I'm buddy slamming the winner of the
contest and closing it out with an
hour-long set and we have new dates
we've added to the budget or tickets go
on sale to the general public April 20
there's still one more day of presale
if you see though if you put down the
code word and L go to a excess comm for
all the dates BAM we did it days coming
up yeah jimmy comedy calm I'm doing a
little West Coast a bunch of
one-nighters Seattle Irvine San Diego
San Francisco of course at our
Sacramento where do you took store
company yet early I started my very
first open mic with the haha comedy club
$5 for five minutes man
yeah that was it I did that for like
maybe two months in the summer and I
went back to college and really I
started in San Diego so mad house comedy
club there was in a different location
back then and then the comedy palace man
that's all right that's my first job I
used to work there the comedy pilot bro
I performed it with them I support them
a lot broke the comedy palace yeah
there's no Greek guys right yes uh well
it's called a Greek palace during the
day yeah and then they changed the
comedy club but then the owners are
actually Syrian yeah whenever they they
like talk it sounds like they argue and
I'm like oh [ __ ] some about to pop off
but really they were just having a
really lovely conversation they just
sound very angry though the first place
we know like when you when you grow up
or and you like something that's good so
you eat a lot of it ate a lot of food
there man yeah yeah with gyro no really
goats no it's mom
it was so good man I forgot the owner's
name but was so full George George I
went to one fly and I went there with
Gary glasses many times yeah yeah um you
know fresh stoller right yeah Freddie
friends always dress yeah he's he's like
one of my like he I probably have
lunches with him the most out of anyone
babysit my cat please he's Grover what
at the Grove man we always go to brother
Mayer yeah he is the mayor of like the
Barnes and Noble at the Grove which
going there sign our own books like it's
you don't get any extra for it now but I
think it makes us a little better like
it bombs to valley of the boat it's like
oh this guy sign it I'll pay a little
more money instead of mine on Amazon or
something you know and the book is all
right now yeah it's out right now it's
been out for like a month it's called
how to American and immigrants got it
disappointing your parents it's it's a
good book for immigrants or not
immigrants or it just people want to you
know listen a funny story if you like
comedy check it out so your parents
where does the point a we want to be a
comedian oh hell yeah they don't know
what stand-up comedy is my dad still
call it a talk show hey Jimmy you gonna
laugh actor do talk show I'm like yeah
whatever
they don't get it right and like they
immigrant I came here when I start teen
so they like uprooted the whole family
for us to have a opportunity to go to
college right and then after I graduated
college I graduate economics degree I
quit an internship that like he sent me
at my dad set me up with and I'm like
that I can't do this he was like what do
you have another job I was like no just
gotta figure this [ __ ] out you know and
I didn't know I wanted to do stand-up
well I didn't even know I could make
stand-up into a career I had three jobs
I was a used-car salesman I worked at
the comedy palace as a doorman and I see
Jade at a strip club when I was in San
Diego this is right after college and
yeah man it was a strip strip almost rip
Club voice yeah alright ladies and
gentlemen coming up we have Jade don't
be shy with you all it two-for-one lap
dance it's going on right now get to lap
dance with a favorite girl
one lap dance with two of your favorite
girls come on I want everybody into the
VIP two for lap dances next ten minutes
there is no shame at strippers I want
your money
DJ savvy side don't be showing those
wallets
I'll ATM run the corner $3 convenience
fee give a little beer put up a stripper
you like with batshit like beautifully
scandalous oh yeah now you can't do that
though cuz like they're independent
contractors man so they can just not go
on stage and that's your ass you know I
mean oh man there's so many crazy store
like this girl they're gonna pay us and
they go up no no no I want to pay me
anything but like did their they can
just walk off they don't they're not
contractually obligated to be there you
know I mean so my job is a struggle of
DJ's to make sure all the girls went on
stage and on time and that's not as easy
as it sounds because some of these
people like you know they don't like men
you know I was an Isis strip club DJ I
was like like the the friendzone strip
club DJ you know put him in they don't
like men it's hard to be a woman and
know that you gotta go out there would
you strip it
understand I know what he's talking
about
that's his first look that was the first
thing he said he didn't say cuz they're
loaded or they're drunk or whatever you
said cuz a lot of them don't like men
and I know what that means like a women
well you end up hating men I think
that's what I feel like I put a show or
they want to come out to guys that's
good the down side bar they don't give a
[ __ ] like there's two P what does one
person and a waiter don't do a show
prime rib is on sale don't be shy with
your wall banks that's like the worst Oh
like when you're like the only customer
in the strip club which is kind of the
cases this triple I worked I just kind
of get on nobody ever go there so
there's usually like two three people
and I have to like high-pressure every
single one of them so like I was like
picking them out I was like doing crowd
work you know like guy with the hat
don't be shy on your wall come on the
guy in the sweats the guy wasn't having
his pocket come on might take a dollar
out yeah very comfortable some people
saying a friend they don't give me no
money huh yeah I kicked him out and I
feel bad no a man like cuz they got it
we we got to have some customer like
it's hard to get a girl's dance it's
like hard to get a comic to do a set
when there's two people they like I
don't want to go out there I'm gonna get
like two bucks and what's is why the
hate women though they hate men they hey
men
why because Leonard I'll grab it on a
mission and also not normal people don't
just go a g-string on right next to a
pole I mean normal people don't just go
and become strippers happen to a lot of
trauma usually like I'm turning the
[ __ ] doctor true but like you know
you're right not a lot of women want to
go do that put themselves on stage no
they don't
a band
my issues father issues or abuse and
trust all of them has had a past and has
involved some [ __ ] up [ __ ] right it's
really sad once you really get to know
her or know them Jimmy oh yeah behind
the world we take a one-on-one interview
me and dr. drew so what did you decide
your mom and dad yeah I know my uncle's
house
you know dr. Phil bump into you and a
cache me outside girl comes out we have
a guest here one time and of strippers
he had no more money and they call his
dad's house yeah doc cuz they be then
you like he they wouldn't they wouldn't
let him leave without paying cuz he ran
up a bill and he told the lady a [ __ ]
this and this and that and they snatched
his cell phone and they called home
damn what's home like wife or like
family ah like good mom and dad 38:30 he
was the same guy that rose up after you
showed me like hey how did you get your
starting comedy man I was about to kill
myself last year but then I saw your
stand-up and then I was okay and he's
like oh [ __ ] how about this one man
after you left the town next week you're
in town there's no editor ma'am
you could stay at our house oh yes I
don't know like why we want to your
house it Lodi budget dog here on the
futon Oh bro God I guess that's people
being nice but it's just like in what
world would I take that offer up maybe I
guess this eight years ago when I was in
San Diego I would like that offer up in
a horror movie
yeah if you have it back in Lubbock
but I feel like why people might take
that offer up though that's like like
some white people [ __ ] like that's why
people hospitality it turns into a
horror movie you know it's like oh yeah
come to come to my house for like
Thanksgiving and like [ __ ] I'm like I
got my whole family later
ain't no one we we love your show man we
got engaged at your show we're getting
married everybody to stop by and do a
set yes yet I gotten so much of that
it's like are we so honored you just
tape a video for my boyfriend cuz he
graduated high school I'm like what the
[ __ ] what I gotta do with this it'll
mean a lot to me and my family and I
thought the whole family pressure on you
oh my god you know there's a site now
it's called I'm baking
okay it's called cameo have you guys
know buddy kept bugging oh yeah there's
a lot of like YouTube celebrities like
monetize it and like bench players in
the NBA and you pay him thirty five
dollars and to do a shout-out video for
you so it's like it's like I don't know
how much money you make him but you
never see nobody
like like that's on a show right now
doing that [ __ ] it's always a
[ __ ] that had a show like 10
years ago it's cancelled Dancing with
the Stars yeah it was a shack give it a
shout out bro that's funny or I'm so the
slope to the soul bro and there's like
35 of them and they're all waiting a
same t-shirt and if part of some charity
uh-huh they drag you in their photo and
they put a t-shirt on you give you
stickers oh yeah and it's oh no I make
them hold my t-shirt then they tell you
why why they're doing it you know it's
for a good cause maybe next time you
cook them yeah we love to have you in
our event like they'll be so nice it's a
nice it's a non-profit I make a hundred
and seventy five thousand a year yeah I
mean it's gonna be not paid for you but
there's a lot of children there they're
gonna love your materials like will you
just listen to myself my matures only
funny between these walls if I write it
down and you read it it could be a very
offensive
my story's not fun if you read it was so
full so we started out in um in San
Diego then he moved out here yeah I
moved out here cuz I was working a strip
club and then like it was getting too
dangerous man like Fritz
it was no no it used to be called
fantasy showgirls
and that was like run by a bunch of
gangsters and stuff and cool it down
no no San Diego I mean oh that was when
I was DJing a strip club was it it
wasn't a chain it wasn't a chain had one
in Fontana oh really good
I saw one out of five strip comedy show
a common yeah Patrick big year
peripheral vision man you know that
comedian path through the year he's the
blind guy yeah maddie was here one time
it was in the game was he good he was a
plane like the team you you were playing
with peripheral at this he was like
reading and Braille on the place on his
flashlight like that that lead to be put
to her show once and I'm this guy was
having a heart attack like I'm a cyborg
eating a steak like having a massive
heart attack oh [ __ ] everybody stopped
eating and that fool like he was the
only one anybody could see what the [ __ ]
so he can't see straight in front of him
I can see on the side this is legally
blind there you go well he only has
peripheral vision yeah yeah that don't
make no sense like how does that so when
he's on stage then he has to turn you
outside staring ahead and he can see
people on the right wow that's crazy you
guys hit him with a paperclip to get my
page then wasn't he I don't know him too
well but he was like a friend of a
friend and he claimed that she made the
the Mexican crossing border t-shirt yeah
like and any like water house off it and
then like Carlos Mencia like like took
it from him or something like that I
don't I don't know sorry that we love to
the city man yeah yeah it's like
somebody like they hacked the national
anthem it's like what the [ __ ] I think
that was my business national anthem
that was my [ __ ] somebody hacked in he
hacked it and then somebody reacted yeah
somebody redone my Statue of Liberty Joe
yeah but that was crazy cuz I'm a crazy
argument because you don't own the sign
it's really long to a city yeah but he
said he bought a house off there yeah
man let's get one of those guys who do
against it and then choice out t-shirts
yeah I am I'm Irish people man like I
respect that like I have so much
troubles like putting myself out there
selling [ __ ] like I always have to have
somebody say like this is how much this
is that and I'm just here to take a
picture
I mean if you want to buy to go talk to
my guy over here it's like I'm so
self-conscious I can't how you're
dealing dealing with money people's
money how can you be like the second one
up on a guest set or if you do a set I
like the comedy magic club or the improv
or some [ __ ] like where there's ten
comedians and then afterwards you got a
whole booth set up outside their car
they don't [ __ ] remember who you are
but Darren Carter hustles and he
actually sells it bro I respect that
because I can't do it hustle oh man I
have to be honest that laugh at you
doing 20 minutes there bro sang a CD
with no cover you sold one that said
Memorex yeah what time I sold 26 of them
for $10 each other times oh wow he had
confidence full confidence in it yeah
you gotta be a sales I'm like so
exhausted after my set like mentally I'm
just like I can't sell your [ __ ] right
well you know chappies bro you don't
know you haven't seen or canon yeah you
walk the tightrope yeah yeah but there's
a lot of those fools man I think there's
certain situations we can do it and then
other dudes like it's a time ball and
the whole they got like a whole shop
selling panties and [ __ ] and underwear
I've seen that I'm like how many sizes
you got to carry around this [ __ ] man
and Joe Johnson I heard she was selling
nail files I can't even speak to that oh
Jesus Christ
do you scores right I've seen everything
Rabab Zinio so everything writers can
old comedians thought eyes he told all
types of [ __ ] like mr. Norris
yeah I forgot a dressing room poof I go
try it on hey baby
they got a return policy you try coming
back on the show it's funny people ask
for a bag bag
Philippe in their photo booth oh but you
know what I did though that changed the
game I want to put the comics on game on
this I take memo now I take vamo and
that [ __ ] is so much easier first of all
because you don't have to exchange cash
that takes another five minutes right
yeah you take vamo and people don't look
at them Oh cash as real money so they're
like Oh 25 bucks on memo that that's
nothing cryptocurrency really well oh no
it's just like bank to bank sort of yeah
yeah it's like it's like usual for
people to split money on a meal Martin
uses it it's like PayPal but it's so
easy till early like memo me at funny
agent do which is the same as on my
Twitter and it's so [ __ ] easy dude
and people don't look at it little money
to just like oh it's like toy money but
then you transfer - it to your bank was
so bad Moe so what you started after
shows what I saw after my shows just
books [ __ ] hand jobs the lap dances
things no just my bullet Punisher the
book and a t-shirt actually I hope you
will buy the t-shirt more I want people
to read the book but I don't make no
money off the book cuz I gotta buy it
off the publisher for like 15 bucks like
25 yeah they didn't did they give you
for period first and friends a family
but I got a [ __ ] you know it's like I
gotta buy it for like the first couple
years until like the paperback comes out
how much do they sell for them on the
shelf and 38 you sure it's retail for 27
full price Amazon sells 2-foot I think
the same and it your shows if you're my
show is 25 but like I'm like I give you
two for one deal if you do the t-shirt
and the book yeah it's 40 bucks you know
I mean just to cover the book or what
the teacher is just picture me like it's
real simple I try to I try to kiss like
the jokes come and go like when I was
younger I always put like a joke like my
punchline to the closure or something
but then you change it out and all those
t-shirts are like worthless and those
people wearing it like they don't know
like people weren't any t-shirt it's
like advertising you right yeah so and
then they gotta explain a piece like
what the foot what's that mean like out
of context sometimes not funny buddy sue
fie
yeah you know like okay I ain't cook
school fire yeah I don't know they they
could used to have super super [ __ ] you
oh yeah people had that t-shirt but he
don't do it no more and their people
have tattoos running around the country
like that Wow
so before your first TV credit to bro
cross two Broke Girls I had two lines on
two Broke Girls Man person in line that
was my big break real man I audition and
like sometimes those roles are harder to
get because it's not like Asian specific
so everybody and their mama it was like
audition for it like right before me
it's like 40 or old white lady you know
it's just person in line you know it's
not Asian person than right so that's
usually not what people are thinking
when they're casting yeah and I was like
late to the audition I was like hustling
because like I part like five blocks
away and they were about to be done with
the casting session but sometimes that's
like when you stop thinking you know
when you're so flustered you're like I'm
just gonna do it and I don't give a [ __ ]
and that's when you get the job
sometimes that's how I felt at the
superstore oh [ __ ] oh yeah yeah because
well they met you before you met the
director the producer and then you
audition two different times for
different things and they didn't pick
you for them but that's when they liked
you though they liked you and then they
just wrote you a little part that's
awesome Nikko Santo he's a homie yeah
yeah you are on Silicon Valley you
started out with a couple lines right
couple lines it was like a co-star bro
because you know co-star means like five
lines or under and then guest stars five
lines or more in one episode it's a
co-star it was like two or three lines
and I got paid like 900 bucks right and
then they wrote me two or three more
lines and they were only so the first
year I made like two grand because I
like five lines total in three episodes
and in the second season I like that
this is like one of my favorite stories
to tell like there's a whole chapter
this in the book was I got offered
because I auditioned for another show
for Yahoo cuz Yahoo was getting into
like original series so it's a
basketball show called extensity saying
scripted show and I got like a main
character series regular part right but
then yahoo was like if you want to do us
you can't do HBO and I didn't know it
first of all Silicon Valley's gonna come
back or if I'm gonna be on Silicon
Valley because I only had like five
words you know I mean
and then I told my agent I'm like dude
we gotta take a chance you know like I
don't know if this Yahoo shows gonna go
and trust me like that I will show paid
like many many times more than that two
grand right and I was a broke-ass comic
and then I was like yo but we got to do
Silicon Alley because that's gonna be a
big show like I can already tell it's
Mike judge yeah yeah and then my agent
was smart enough she was like okay let
me call HP I'll see what they won't
match the offer and make it a series
regular and I was like yo don't even do
that cuz that's funny crazy experience
tupid like just think I'm gonna greedy
person like whatever and it's just like
no just trust me let me do it and then
it did it and HBO said yes like they
want to keep me around and you know keep
that agent you know she she made us a
move that's crazy that's good but you do
get worried about asking for things like
that but that's why you have agent I
know the agent is the one who takes the
hit everybody out sort of t between
you're rich off those fine lines no for
real I was driving uber between season
one and to Silicon Alley bro aren't you
that dude I'm like nah we're doing right
now yeah yeah what's up this Cash Cab or
what was it like working without TJ
Miller he was awesome man
he was like the homie and like if I
don't know you know before though right
I I ran into him but like we're never
like boys or anything yeah like I just
seen him around and I don't think he
knew who I was but like he's so [ __ ]
good right here any improv so well that
he keeps you on your toes and like we we
earned this trust with each other and it
was like instant chemistry where like I
know if I thought some crazy [ __ ] he
would give me the perfect response I
mean he throws out some crazy [ __ ] I got
him you know I mean like we understand
the dynamic and yeah man like he was
like my boy on the show dude was that
weed on the show everybody oh and I
don't know if everybody smokes weed but
I think that's uh yeah that's a weed
smoking community well the sauce on it
sony sony yeah all of it even the other
side sometimes there's the exterior the
house is somewhere in a real house here
and then
what's called like sometimes once a year
we'll go to San Francisco for like the
news interview segment and like like the
exterior like say say like the giant
Stadium or something like that yeah but
mostly should I hear how much of the
punch line that you drew in our improv
how much so they let us do it a lot of
times you through enough funniest line
and they cut to to another scene but it
was hilarious - laughing that when you
brought them yeah you brought those
cigarettes now's a good time
oh yeah this special changing with the
same yeah that became a thing cause like
it was like I always smoke on special
occasions that was one episode and then
now like ever since then loud now every
time I character does something cool I
was asked a prop guy I'm like give me a
cigarette
you know you should probably smoke it
you know so um yeah we try to add stuff
in there but the writing is already so
good so even if you don't it's like
awesome and whenever you do get a line
that you or an action sometimes
improving it's not just a line right
it's like an action like that leads to
maybe some more lines like in one of the
episode that where's this baby shower I
went away and I came back we're like a
little you know a skim milk chalice that
like you put in the coffee and I start
like drinking in front of TJ and I just
asked Mike I was like as if gonna be
funny about do this and I was like let's
try it so just like sometimes finding
props fun you know trying stuff and that
led to like pretty funny moment you know
I mean so yeah they let us try stuff and
then sometimes the writers and the
directors would be there and they will
throw us lines - yeah so you got you got
a bigger row another TJ man is gone yeah
I mean I was sad man well from the go
yeah and I was like worried I was like
oh [ __ ] like a bird Alec Burg's Alec
Berg's a great do but I think I don't
know from the Articles that I've read
you know they didn't see eye to eye but
um he's a great writer and TJ's a really
good you know comedic actor it just
sometimes the chemistry don't worry he's
do them as children he could have done
more movies yeah he he called me and he
was like I'm quitting the show because I
I need to spend more time doing movies
and me and my wife we want to go move to
New York and do more comedy you know so
um I was like man I wish you stay he was
like now you know my mind's made up
and uh and you know what but it turned
into for the show wise for my character
wise to turn into a blessing in disguise
you know because now my guy gets to do a
little more and fill in some of that
void she was a bad guy no in the show
yeah man it's pretty fun so many they're
like tweeting me now they're like I
[ __ ] hate you this season which is
great right because like that's the
purpose of it and then you see there's a
whole arc of it he becomes like pretty
like a pretty super villain when you
actually took over the house and you
were smoking a cigarette right yeah you
got any apps can't come in no just like
I love the character I hope you went to
China with that's the last episode you
went to start the new new Internet a lot
of people are very worried I'm worried
they're like oh [ __ ] is this the end of
jingyang and the house is watching that
cliffhanger
he's like bootlegging all this stuff in
the Chinese market and they're
duplicating a lot so we can duplicate it
all a lot of times it's because because
the government doesn't let you use
Facebook and Google over there so they
have to engineer something new so some
of it comes from ingenuity with
somewhere they come from you know
happiness or whatever but pirated
yeah their technology is [ __ ] way
more advanced in us sometimes like the
facial recognition [ __ ] they have
cameras every corner now my brother lost
his [ __ ] wallet right like just on
the street he went to like the police
station they tracked the goddamn wallet
from a lady picking it up to a lady like
you know putting it in a store like to
return it for something and they got it
the next day man
so it is it is very scary in a way cuz
like we don't want to be servants that's
the Facebook thing but China is already
doing that like to the max we have
cameras here too though and now when
they're sawed they're solving all crime
yeah well there's a hard time because
Jim is eating a bowl well yeah and I had
I worked with this girl at the law firm
a few years ago she was my office
partner and she was from China and she
did a lot of visiting over there because
her family was coming over and they were
gonna do some importing and stuff in the
US she would go over there and she said
that they have like all the supermarkets
you can check yourself out you have your
own little scanner on your phone
everybody uses it and they can just pay
that way and leave the store and never
interact their spatial recognition when
you cross in the street so you get
jaywalk if you want but then there's a
giant TV right here like like 100 inches
that will broadcast your [ __ ] face
and shame you I'm not making this [ __ ]
up like this is for real dude
yeah that's your own premiere and they
said they had caught three thousand
criminals that's in a database based on
facial recognition and machine learning
because of this camera technology in one
year in the u.s. the US government has
partnered with Google already doing that
here yeah but now because of these
privacy concerns it's kind of been put
on hold but they've already started
working with machine learning facial
recognition I think China's got a speed
you know you for that [ __ ] Philippe for
what for facial recognition all that
[ __ ] or keep your privacy don't record
me I don't know I feel like there's
gonna be a lot of false positive I don't
care what you do man Oh outside of the
comedy just only don't stay in front
recording my show and put on your story
right away
yeah I hate that [ __ ] you get that lap
you record your whole show and put on
the story sometimes I think usually the
clubs make announcements now like right
there's two people there's an audience's
follow the rules on that the best point
Phillipe it makes two though when he
says that to somebody is it why would
you give this [ __ ] away for free yeah
money for this [ __ ] show dog promoter
what is [ __ ] giving away brother
wouldn't give it away so they can look
cool for the lights right well there you
go that's great
like back in the day celebrities are
like or basketball players are worried
like when they like go go have sex or
with a random woman in the city like
like she's gonna take a picture and then
send it to the wife blackmail like
whatever now just like the growth just
story the [ __ ] like yo I'm hanging out
with Tristan Thompson yeah that's how
you know that's how you get rolled you
know I mean like it's not it's not cool
man
so you have a girlfriend no no right now
oh so you've been touring right yeah you
bet winning city you never been to that
you were surprised it was sold out oh
you know what like this tour like all
the cities is so that I was [ __ ] like
stoked but we pick cities there you sold
out
yeah and that's very bad my special
there oh really that's a good grave
venue right yes ma'am yeah go good good
have good people people take care of you
there it's like a classic theater yeah
like Houdini's do it the green room is
nice too you can look down on the people
yeah and they say it's haunted
yeah yeah that no it's great um San Jose
at like San Francisco that's my core fan
base right it's Silicon Valley people
and Asian people because that's my
family so poor people don't watch us
look I'm Ally which is usually younger
feeling like 25 to 40 that's in the tech
world and or Asian people a lot of Asian
people know me from stand-up and I
learned about me and like cell komali or
whatever so when those two group come
together in like San Francisco and San
Jose it's a [ __ ] hot show man I love
it like Boston it's less Asian fans it's
like maybe six Asian fans but it's all
like Silicon Valley white people friends
fans so it's a different response to
certain jokes they're Texas Texas I
haven't done it I'm gonna go to Austin I
think I was setting up a date there but
other parts of Texas I don't know man
and certain parts people just don't
watch Silicon Valley you know and
there's not Asian people so when that
happens I don't know I'm afraid if I'm
like I might not sell like Houston
there's a lot of Asian so I might be a
little problem
Seattle shouldn't be a problem yeah Long
Beach I haven't really done Long Beach
maybe everybody fine yeah
definitely for sure yeah that's me good
we were we were I was a New Brunswick
bro the stress factory where's New
Brunswick exactly like I was at the
stable oh my the Hyatt Hotels Danette
with across the street from a cemetery
uh-huh then it wasn't a building did an
alley and the comedy cooler was there
that's amateur brenda forever the
Declaration of Independence was read
there at the cemetery yeah 1750s and
[ __ ]
yeah did you sell out you sell out hell
no not there oh so - it was packed but
not so dad it was to the rim they kept
all giving away bonuses obviously now
your crowds mostly Latino see those so
like when that like New Jersey is not a
lot of Latinos I'm gay there's a lie but
then they drove up real far though yeah
yeah there was all right Latinos
Peruvians Porto Ricans
yeah beans Mexicans do Ricans yeah Costa
Ricans all types do you see different
responses from different Latinos like
Mexicans might laugh at this joke but no
they never everything yeah it's pretty
umbrella or so that people don't get
they get it but those are a medics and
do some Paraguayan Joe gonna be like
Russell Peters dude jokes by everybody
but only Latino very specific Latino
communities you get mo people tell you
what the request I got a big man fall I
got a big long fan base in Minnesota man
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah in the Midwest
has a lot of little pockets yes
[ __ ] I got to do some Clint Eastwood
jokes now used to call that kid on that
movie oh he called me I never know about
these racist terms I swear I learned
like like my zipper head yeah but he
constantly call that kid some weird-ass
name though it's like though this white
man is teaching me like racist terms
about Asian people man yeah slope
something like that I don't know
zipper head I don't know man I remember
yeah toad
he took my Torino he gave him that
Torino da so uh well you've been a movie
when we've been on yes so Patriot a
that's one of my first big movies is a
traumatic part about the Boston Marathon
bombing we're like Mark Wahlberg Kevin
Bacon all those JK Simmons all those
guys it was a really good movie but not
too many people watched it because it's
such a hard subject to watch like
terrorism especially with the world that
we live in now you don't want to go
relive it in theater you know but it's a
very very powerful movie and now back to
more comedy
I didn't movie that just about to come
out Mother's Day when Melissa McCarthy
called life of the party so they don't
all promos now and it's coming out May
11th and I just did this movie called I
did this movie last year called crazy
rich Asians that's mega star movie right
that's gonna hopefully be huge because
it's the first studio movie with a full
Asian cast in 25 years since Joy Luck
Club yeah so it's every Asian you can
[ __ ] think of right Ken Jong's in it
I'm in at Jon toe aquafina John chose
not in it because mostly it's Chinese
pal right and then you got like British
actresses like so annoying Mizuno Jemma
Chan who's like pretty joke boy jo koy
no he's not I think I like Australian
people like me he's like you know like
Michelle Yeoh is in it you know
Crouching Tiger you know of course and
didn't know how to speak Chinese when
she started and I taught her films she
learned phonetic she learned from bTW ah
so the Green Hornet yeah so that movie's
gonna be big I saw a screening of it
what was that when did that one come out
where they're all taking a test and
they're cheating on the test
oh I'll compete aright yeah they were
chasing and it was like then ladies or
early 2000
me I think tomato - ordinate no Jon Chu
director
and not John shook at dammit Justin Lin
director better luck tomorrow tomorrow
and they're cheating on like SATs I
think or something a major test right
yeah Sun King to do that ended up on
fast and furious yeah Joe might have
been in it you might might be right yeah
yeah yeah but that's an indie that kind
of years ago tomorrow yeah
but we'll make it work no no no as an
agent that's your the dragon you know
the last dragon I had all the all the
agents from the 80s who are also in Big
Trouble in Little China farewell my
concubine
oh wow that dudes and everything his
name
something Hong he's again every he was
in Blade Runner okay it was in big
trouble Oh China to think if I'm focused
he's good
focus oh I haven't seen that movie what
Martha Roby yeah yeah oh not that I'm
thinking of something else
alright okay what's our Julie that shows
coming up April 28th that nice lappers
in Whittier and also June 15th Riverside
we're doing a once a month show at the
box which is the little room next to the
Fox Theater nice Yemen were you in
Patriots Day yeah she's busy no I was
reading stuff cuz everybody's en este no
muy
everybody said you're it was in Patriots
Day opposite Mark Wahlberg go watch and
then and that Jimmy is arguably he has
arguably the role the most important
person in the story without him they
don't it's it's pretty crazy wonder
fresh Joseph s kiss well it's based on a
real story right so you know you kind of
know I'll get you a blu-ray next time I
see you oh yeah I'll get you but I gotta
get you a book to [ __ ] whatever elbow
you live around here
yeah here
we live in Bali I should have brought it
well support it so when I'm clubbed you
call your home club now I don't know I
go to the improv once or twice a week I
don't I don't Hollywood yeah I don't get
to go up too much cuz I got [ __ ] to do
at night sometimes and I want to write
more I want to turn that book in a TV
show I think that's first and foremost
right now and but yeah I'm the improv I
think they treat me really well
the comedy star never kind of really
messed with I used to go laughs actor
quite a bit but then but then a laugh
actor start doing this [ __ ] what do you
just put videos up of you actually only
send them an email like I didn't get
information about a lot of people stop
doing like I can [ __ ] sue you for
this do you understand like this is not
cool like you can [ __ ] [ __ ] over ass huh
they asked I never replied and they
[ __ ] put it up anyways I'm like yo I
can't be doing this [ __ ] yo the thing
you're Jake huh no I'm sure they owe me
some money in the box office I didn't go
pick it up no I check with a bigger what
they do right they do give you a cut of
the YouTube money but they need to ask
for permission they can't be you you can
ask them to stop doing it and to only
ask you for going on and you can say I
don't know jokes I'm not again always
you know I mean yeah I'm gonna tell them
to take down a couple video and some you
gotta have a check for the rest they
record everything your audition for
Jamis Allah Allah Susie's Oh years ago
yeah I already go man I think when I got
rang that Bell to get off oh do what's
that dude's name burger
I don't know he was so mean to everyone
yeah it was okay with me but I guess and
like he says he's like a [ __ ] cult
leader right now he sells you on the
streams like does this sensation you get
on and you know a lot of comics get on
this and then and then you know they
make it from here so this is yeah you he
probably get some suck jobs in the great
green room we should [ __ ] hash tag me
to that [ __ ] I hated him he just
like such like preying on these young
young people you know and I was young I
was I was the little guy no no that the
other did Jamie smile right yeah the
older do Ed McMahon
yeah here on the side and he makes sure
we start being dirty yeah
good night good night only there on oh
good and who the [ __ ] was that guy fella
work there and I never saw that I never
probably like when you know the Marx
Brothers scariest comedian the world
there on Tuesday morning I am yeah yeah
some well then we're not even going to
go walk with the do thing I'll talk it
to you waiting for the Thanksgiving
dinner yeah you in dinners of that
Patrick I know I usually go half dinner
at my family's I would like to do that
it was fun for a while but it became a
press thing like everybody show up at
the one o'clock dinner because that's
when all the press would show up and it
was some big communal show well just to
serve one turkey getting in front of the
camera kids LA yeah and then we would go
up like some of the comments would go up
and give free comedy shows you know dude
like five minutes here and there
just had to be clean because they're
kids there too and old people and stuff
TMZ is always asked are they improv now
and and and the thing is that guy I
forgot his name Justin or something the
nicest guy on the planet so you I can't
I feel bad saying no sometimes but like
he be asking me sometimes funny
questions but sometimes be asking me
like about TJ and something like I'm
gonna talk about that that's not like
yes homeboy on blast yeah you know like
I know he was the homie man like so I
don't you know I got none bad to say
about that man I was doing a show and
Des Moines Iowa I wanted for where one
night on a Sunday and I was teaching me
a little headline in the week but he
wasn't doing Sunday show but again he
stood there for Sunday party so he went
to my show to hang out and I full hook
me I was so a grandma Hasbro yeah like I
went on stage they maybe wouldn't hit a
ball
hell yeah he was over having some hash
and grow a [ __ ] [ __ ] I got it there
too then um somebody else he he had
somebody hooked me with a little nugget
and some papers because I all have good
weed or did he bring that I don't know
where he got it from here a friend there
oh [ __ ] yeah I wanted a University of
Iowa that was really fun our city it's
like Cedar Rapids no yes yes right next
to it I it's our city you find in the
Cedar I think yeah yeah it was it was
really cool man that University is like
it's like Austin you know like it's very
liberal like very like friendly and it's
a lot of walking around one of the Cedar
Rapids I'm a little show and then after
the show they took me it took me around
the city and there was an Asian market
that sold probably all the stuff for
every Chinese restaurant in that in that
town and they had everything brought I
hate about five coconut waters I saw the
last you at home man man yeah nothing
but masculine buying show though what's
up fool shut up - Toby hates my homey
man every hop hop with a hammer
Hollywood alhambra arcadia my parents of
Monrovia so all the time like that's
gives me a good reason to drive an hour
to go there get as good as Mexicans we
love some Chinese luck yeah you grew up
in one row where you grew up in LA
likewise LA oh yeah when I came here
yeah I want a John Burroughs middle
school we're John Burroughs middle
school and then my dad used a fake
address to go to um for me to go to
Beverly Hills High School my mom to use
a fake ID my mom my dad my mom to fake a
dress for my brother could go up drop
out of John Marshall where's John
Marshall don't watch your high school is
that Silver Lake is it not a good school
it's a good school okay so quick go
there yeah that's cool bro bro you're
I went to Palisades but that was not for
a fake address it was a blessing program
well that's magnet program there being
bussed from the whole policy Fidel here
to that foot mister but I'm gonna beat
his ass all the way to the [ __ ]
miss the bus but mohel has to take that
for her the car beating his what did he
go to crazy college after that like from
because he wanted a college the upward
mobility kind of stalled Jam out of his
house rocking chair no for real yeah Jam
like like like crepes yeah is he making
business I don't know ain't gonna be one
of them people on Shark Tank well I
remember you see it up at a picnic with
a [ __ ] box y'all got a father oh and
they trying to sell you oh my god you
try making actually you get your friends
they'll come in on this sometimes I just
do it cuz I'm like just so you gonna
[ __ ] stop asking me [ __ ] you know so
I don't know your [ __ ] same times you
have to go I got this woman that she
used to be a nurse when I when I hurt
myself in San Diego and like she was
like my nurse and she was like really
like the nice nurse and then every year
since then she will hit me up with a new
business idea on Facebook I'm like your
money guy John that was a voice--a one
time yeah it's like amway cosmetic that
crazy rose it was crazy because I was
waiting tables saving up to move to New
York and um this one job I was working I
were three jobs so one of the jobs there
was this woman she's a housewife middle
age she she starts selling Amway I had
no idea about Amway except that they had
this cleaning product that I liked cuz
my the office I worked at it in college
they used this cleaning father
it was non chemicals and all the stuff
so I said hey I'm interested in buying
some of that stuff she said oh let me
show you some of the products so she
brings me the catalog I looked through
it okay again I want this this and this
okay
I'll bring it over so she asks when I
could when she could come
/ with her friend and I was like why
don't know why your friend that's to
come but whatever is one yeah over to my
apartment it was a bringer yeah she
shows up with this guy who's in a suit
I'm 2021 I'm 21 years old right house
it's fraser-smith shout out shout out
there's a there's a bong sitting on my
coffee table it's a it's a mess we go
into the living room I don't have heat
in my living room because it's so cold
like in the winter we shut off the
radiator or the vents to that room
because there's so many windows and
holes in the walls and stuff so we're
freezing in the living room he goes is
there a warmer room to go to something
all right so we go to the kitchen we're
sitting in the kitchen we're still cold
we're all wearing our coats and he
starts opening up this book about how
rich I can be and I thought I was just
getting some cleaning products for my
friend I just wanted to order and pay
her further you can't do it huh can you
just like one you try to get pulled into
being a salesperson for them immediately
if I was like your wing I hate selling
first of all and I didn't like I was
horrible I did a show one time where
where I'm the only hotel they had was in
this place in Las Vegas but outside
thought there was timeshare people all
day yo we should sell timeshares four
merch and my see it I got this timeshare
in India yeah but even [ __ ] 20
t-shirts all right you didn't come back
with $400 yeah was so full so what is
your Instagram and your social media
funny Asian dude that's a Twitter and
Instagram go follow me at funny Asian
dude and go to my website jimmy comedy
calm on a tourist coming up and
everything else you can buy the book on
there too awesome
so maybe if you're looking for someone
to open for you and submerge man
[Laughter]
I know again I can make t-shirts bro oh
yeah is he gonna hook me up or I got a
Pam do you know a guy that shoots videos
also under guys I need a videographer
for my show so you can do five if you
pay for a review video you probably got
a t-shirt for you want to hang out the
show too lightweight why we have the
perfect t-shirt people they don't want
anything and they don't want to come
back and hang out in the show what do
they sell t-shirts for you know they
make t-shirts for us but they don't want
anything beyond our transaction of
buying shirts that they make for me
where's your shirt guy like he's on Pico
he's in Midtown like um well they call
they're called Sunday print companies
and a print company yeah how much is
shirt
on average and I'm it's a little bit
more than I've had in the past but it's
like on average it's about eight dollars
a shirt okay 425 but I thought we saw in
425 but some we take a cut we take a hit
because we get bigger shirts we go up to
3x and we don't charge people anymore
smile you gotta go 3x on a small six six
yeah but it's more expensive so we take
a hit on that so it's average about
eight dollars a shirt but it's worth it
because they never are late they never
make a mistake I never have any mess I
have I had some in the past that were
just nightmares and these guys are the
best I found a company that yeah I found
a company in Kansas City they charge me
a little more like it's not that much on
shipping but it's like so much cheaper
over there so like they and they just
ship it straight to comic-con that's a
good idea
yeah think about yes yes ship them
they're sure they'll make them there
wait what am in the shirts the shirts
yeah yeah make it in Kansas City so they
can either like right now I'm doing like
a bunch of like Irvine that I can drive
to like San Diego so I just haven't ship
it to me but they could ship it to like
Chicago saying if you want I like
whatever you're still on your website
and stuff too out of your house I need a
big stock for that oh yeah because I
don't I don't want to be folded up
t-shirt somebody's your buddy somebody
old teachers yeah I need an assistant
I do shows coming up right where we told
them yeah April
we that a nice clappers in a June 15 the
first one in roofs I'd be there once a
month Jimmy comedy calm you can see all
shows Seattle Irvine San Francisco San
Diego all that for a long time I'll
finish fresh dollar asking us to have
you in a podcast oh really he's the best
I was just talking to me oh you'll be do
he'll do well on their birthday part of
town he invited me tonight an hour
before the party yo that party was lit
dr. Drew was there yeah who Kerry was
there and like a bunch of like old-timey
like awesome
like comedians like this yeah bro watch
Omar's was there like Fred's generation
of people which is great yeah Bob Saget
was there bro yeah no he was what some
fool that you got to listen in the worst
awful podcast
shoutout to everybody that was on
YouTube live right now oh yeah here
follow me on youtube I think it's slash
lowball Jim that's my channel I just I
have a channel on YouTube it's growing
it's happening I believe that's my stage
name when I want to stage at first this
trip